there's no evidence that individual da
in his office is any more punitive today
than he was in 1974 we just have 30,000
of them instead of 17,000 you know the
climb raised roughly the same as it was
1977 they gotta do something
it is can't believe mine super all-day
keep their jobs and the fact is we admit
600,000 people that prison every year
but we arrest 12 million people every
year if you're a DA need to find a case
to keep your job we have 12 million
cases from which you can draw you will
find a case you can prosecute and so
they prosecute I'd like to open this
discussion with a quote from a former
attorney General Robert Jackson who
remarked in 1940 that quote the
prosecutor has more control over life
liberty and reputation than any other
person in America it's been 75 years
since that comment was made and yet
prosecutors have only solidified their
power over the fate of defendants in
that time yet we know relatively little
about the culture within prosecutors
offices and how they operate at the
local level when I originally started to
plan this event last year the election
hadn't taken place and since then a lot
has happened especially at the federal
level that makes this discussion timely
er than ever and I'm thrilled to have
two experts here to speak on these
issues both with experience one with the
experience of the former prosecutor
another who had studied the criminal
justice system for years who all
introduced now so first to my immediate
left is John faff John faff is a law
professor at Fordham Law School where
his research has focused primarily on
understanding the causes of mass
incarceration and what it will take to
scale back our reliance on prison his
new book locked up which is right here
argues that we systematically miss miss
state the causes of mass incarceration
overlooking the central role of
prosecutors prison guard unions and the
need to rethink how we handle crimes of
violence if it weren't for Twitter okay
I didn't write those jaundice
if it weren't for Twitter some New York
City therapist would be far far richer
today he's very active on Twitter you
guys should follow him and to the far
left is Ken white he's a partner at
brown white and Osborn LLP in Los
Angeles he began his career as a federal
prosecutor in the US Attorney's Office
in Los Angeles and went into private
practice in 2001 since then he's
practiced criminal defense and
litigation with an emphasis on First
Amendment cases Ken also writes the
criminal justice and free speech blog
Pope at and has frequently and
frequently writes about criminal justice
issues and other publications so let's
give a round of applause to our
panelists
okay so jumping into the discussion my
first question is for Jon Jon in your
book you refer to prosecutors as the man
behind the curtain and argue that few
people in the criminal justice system
are as powerful or adcentral to prison
growth as the prosecutor could you talk
a little bit about why we know so little
about these actors so it's simple the
reason we knows too little about them is
they tell us almost nothing what they do
we have lots of data on crimes and
policing a lot of data on prisoners and
parole and probation
we literally have no data on what
prosecutors do and as a result they kind
of get ignored in the process my
favorite example of this was that when
Hillary Clinton rolled out her end and
criminal justice reform plan she talked
about police and she talked about parole
but she never mentioned prosecutors it
wasn't end-to-end it was end and end and
she skipped over the middle but the
middle is actually where all the work
happened all right so just to briefly
summarize my reason why I care so much
about prosecutors now is that my work
looked at sir what why did prison
populations grow even as crimes fell
over the 90s in 2000 and when we find it
during that time crime Falls series
crime Falls a lot serious property in
serious violent crimes all fall a 20 30
% and arrests fall we don't arrest more
people for all the CSI stuff going on on
TV the number of rests fell every year
so our arresting fewer and fewer people
but more and more people are going to
prison
why is because the chance an arrest
turns into a felony case skyrockets once
that felony charge is filed the
probability go to prison doesn't change
once you go to prison amount of time you
spend in prison
it hasn't changed in about 20 years for
all we talked about long sentences it's
been fairly stable the only thing that
changed is a chance that an arrest turns
to the felony case and it's entirely
within the discretion of prosecutors do
that they have been the single most
important force driving up prison
populations and no one is really talking
about them or has it maybe the past year
they started that but no reform plan
targets them no policy brings them out
there they're overlooked in almost every
discussion we have no data what they've
used is very hard to pin down what's
going on and so we serve it just for all
it's going on I think one reason why our
results been so anemic right no it's one
of the few true bipartisan issues is
prison reform when the only case there
was a left and right generally come
together and yet if you take California
the picture we barely drop their prison
population the United States hasn't
leaked our straight in California has
you know started tagging along along the
side and these guys are focusing on all
the wrong people and ignore the posse is
a big part of that so Ken you had direct
experience working as a young federal
prosecutor in fact you've written about
that your career started when you were
26 years old on the day that OJ Simpson
was acquitted and could you talk about
your experience as a 20-something year
old who was given this enormous amount
of power over the lives of your fellow
citizens and what that was like sure I
mean the thing to understand is that
prosecutors during this time period
while crime has fallen have been given
more and more discretion more and more
decision-making ability more and more
choice about whether something goes to a
felony or not whether something goes or
not and yet there's no accompanying
methodical rigorous look how that
discretion is exercised why it's
exercised and about the culture that
influences it so what I quickly found in
the culture as a ridiculously young
federal prosecutor is that there are
very strong views that drive all that
type of discretion it's it's sort of us
against the world mentality that's fed
by our sort of law and order or us
against them type of culture it's a fear
not so much fear of crime which
certainly the culture pushes but fear of
you know God helped me if I'm the one
who isn't harsh enough against this guy
and he goes out and kills somebody that
fear and it's the sense of camaraderie
which is wonderful but it's also part of
us against them culture that means that
you know if anyone is saying something
wrong was done if anyone is saying that
you're unreasonable here if anyone
saying there was misconduct
that's them against us and we don't look
at it the same way we would at other
places we don't second-guess you know we
act as a team all those factors I found
very young come together and a lot of
prosecutors are very young and when you
you know walk into a federal
prosecutor's office at 26 is incredibly
difficult to resist that culture and to
make your own decisions to come out
someplace different and as a result I
agree with your on that prosecutors the
person behind the curtain but I I see it
more as like the culture behind the
curtain the system behind the curtain
where it's not so much the individuals
the way they are shaped by the entire
system and there's a systematic approach
to cases that that most of the public
doesn't really understand so kicking it
back to John I guess you can sort of
take this one first in your view what
role have prosecutors played in creating
what is commonly referred to as mass
incarceration I know that's basically
your entire book so that's kind of a big
question but I would like to hear your
take on it and yeah and Ken as well and
so I mean the role they played is this
decision on their part to just file more
and more felony charges and so the
question we want to ask is why like what
what change to make them more punitive
and I think there's lots of things so I
think part of it is that the deck
stacked very much in their favor not
just the way the code is written but we
have a nominally adversarial system or
one side isn't funded right so we spend
more on prosecutors and to have public
defense even though 80 percent of all
people facing prison time qualify for a
public defender and that's the best case
scenario the state to recharge indigent
defendants for their interesting lawyer
and it's even worse than that because
public defenders pay for their
investigators prosecutors don't because
their investigators go by the name
police department all right they get
that for free they get DNA services are
free and North Carolina found out that
while the DA and the public defender
budgets in North Carolina are equal if
you add in all the free services the DA
gets at the public defender stone the
DA's have a budget three times that the
public defenders I suppose defenders
will be overwhelmed by the other side's
interfaces part of it though I think
this is a really boring story what most
of what my work finds is that the things
that really matter the most tend to be
the most boring things because it's
really interesting and important we
fixed it and was interesting unimportant
we talked about it
but was boring and it matters who wants
to talk about that right so I will talk
to you forever
about how the census drives mass
incarceration right and it does because
you got to figure out where those
prisoners count is living that's a huge
deal and lots of state representatives
lose their seat their prison closes but
that's boring but it but it matters
where it goes the prosecutors is hiring
there are two very interesting hiring
patterns Jia's prosecutors between 1974
and 2008 the number of counties with a
full-time prosecutor goes to 45 percent
to 85 percent that's a rural suburban
phenomenon all these small counties you
have some part-time guy was a private
practice who did caves on the side now
he is the DA this is his job this is
what he does and of course I gave me
harsher harsher and we see now actually
that the rural counties remained by far
the most peanut counties in the country
now the other pattern we see is that
between 1974 and 1990 as crime goes up
substantially we hire 3,000 prosecutors
from 17,000 to 20,000 as crime drops
over the 90s and 2000's we hired 10,000
more prosecutors with 20,000 of 30,000
less than left and less crime and a
giant ramping up in staffing
there's no evidence that an individual
DA in his office is any more punitive
today than he was in 1974 we just have
30,000 of them instead of 17,000 you
know the crime rate roughly the same as
it was 1970
or they'd guide you something I did is
can't play minesweeper all day and keep
their jobs and the fact is we admit six
hundred thousand people to prison every
year but we arrest 12 million people
every year if you're a DA mean to find a
case to keep your job we have 12 million
cases from which you can draw you will
find a case you can prosecute and so
they prosecute because that's what
they're hired to do and no it's boring
and it's Human Resources is the cause of
the problem right but there are a lot of
these structural problems that do it
there are other problems we have I think
the other one I think is always to to
point out is that DA's are elected by
the county jail and probation the lesser
sentences those are paid for by the
county but prison is paid for by the
state so if you're a DA why send them to
jail if you get sent into prison because
it's actually cheaper for you to send in
the prison because that takes them off
your County's budget and puts them on
the state budget rather than your
probation or jail they keep them on your
County's budget again budgets like what
makes people glaze over and run away
from your party staff so when we talk
about budget and the census right and
Human Resources those are three things I
want to talk to you bout you also have
the death penalty in a war on drugs no
it's human resources it's it's budgetary
politics and it's it's dissensus right
but these things really matter and they
don't get nearly as much attention as as
they should thank you yeah all right
yeah go ahead Ken's do you have a follow
up on how prosecutors what role they
have played in creating mass
incarceration sure just to give it
another example to what John was talking
about in California there like in a lot
of places there used to be a division
between municipal courts and superior
courts right used to have some courts
for that would have smaller civil
matters and misdemeanors and some courts
that had felonies and eventually as a
structural budget saving measure and
kind of push them all together into one
big court system well the natural
consequence of that is more and more
stuff is getting treated as a felony
rather than a misdemeanor because I mean
if you can go all the way to the top
point up go right why do a misdemeanor
you have
now to do a felony that type of thinking
because there we've got to use it
because we're a hammer there's got to be
a nail drives that type of thing
sounds completely right that you know
the population of prosecutors keeps
growing and there's always going to be
something they can find to do there's
also been a change particularly more
recently in the priorities of
prosecutors so I was lucky enough to
come up during a time where I got to
work in what they called the the
government fraud and public corruption
section some you know we did in cases a
the police abused environmental crime
civil rights violations corruption by
public officials that section briefly
got phased out in the 2000s when we
decided we have to do everything you
know anti-terrorism terrorism being
given a rather generously broad
definition there's a shift in priorities
to we've got to do violent crime and
violent being very broadly defined drug
crime immigration crime property crime
we've got to do more numbers more volume
and less time is spent on things that
maybe would have an influence in society
I mean for what it takes for federal
prosecutors to take down a crooked
congressman you can do you know 30 bank
robberies and 30 drug cases and 30 gang
cases resource-wise if you want to have
impressive numbers you're going to put
people in federal prison for that type
of thing you're not going to take down
someone who is corrupting the system
fundamentally and I guess I also had in
fairness to prosecutors a big reason why
they're harsh is also just on okay we
stay in survey after survey that we want
people to be less punitive focus more on
rehabilitation less on punishment but we
go to the voting booth we vote based on
that one shocking case is all it takes
so people my age it's no really Horton
right that one bad case that that we
believe it didn't actually sink to
caucus this presidential campaign but
certainly didn't help it or even more
recent example of Darryl Dennis who is a
parolee in Arkansas Arkansas passed a
major foreign law prison population
dropped by ten percent Darryl Dennis has
a single parolee who commits a single
murder and parole probation shut down
sofa
that 10% job became I met 7% increase in
a single year
right and prosecutors know this they
know we say no don't be harsh played you
mess again signal mistakes we're going
to nail you that for that and there's an
jets how deep disappear this runs in our
culture this hit me the other day I
never struck it all through law school
even my survey this book and never hit
me think about the opening credits to
the original Law & Order keep are
represented by to the people are
represented with equal branches the
police who investigate crime and the
prosecutors who prosecute them judges
public defenders parole boards no no two
people cops in DA's public defenders
don't exist right the defendants aren't
part of society right there somewhere
else you know didn't realize it until
years and wait like their entire other
half of the bureaucracy you've cut all
that equation that technotrekker uses us
in terms of defense and neutrality but
you know it's so embedded you don't
these I didn't appreciate that for years
how bias that way yeah we suck that's
the way I put that very close with well
that's that's a good segue to my next
question because you know because be it
change and many are elected most of this
is kind of a political debate it's all
about implementing the wishes of voters
if they want punitive sentences you know
why would the DA go against that
so I guess why should we focus so much
on prosecutors and instead of like state
policy and Bill's because I know that in
your book you always talk about why we
should focus on prosecutors so elect
earier response to that so the catch is
is that who are the people we're talking
about right so prosecutors are elected
by the county but at least when it comes
the cities city counties consist of two
things the city and the suburbs there
are part of a county there are
exceptions right no New York flips it
around Baltimore st. Louis temperatures
but don't have rain suburbs like Chicago
right half of Cook County lives in
Chicago
half of Cook County does not live in
Chicago could cause a whole votes for
the DA what that does is ensure that the
wealthier whiter more conservative
suburbs play dis apportion role in
electing a prosecutor who then enforces
law in the poor more minority areas
where street crime tends to be
concentrated and that creates an
incredibly dangerous
separation of costs and benefits
the suburbs feel of benefits of of
aggressive time control policies right
they feel safer going to see for work
they feel safer going to say on a Friday
night they feel safer believing quite or
going to see that drugs are going some
of their kids schools because they're
cracking it down the cities because
that's obviously doing plays high school
suburban drugs come from other cities
but they don't feel the call right it's
not their uncle not their brother not
their son not their nephew not their
father not their sister who's being
unneeded ously stopped arrested charged
convicted incarcerated right and so das
have a strong incentive to overreact
so yes it's politics but the politics
are skewed right in that those who don't
bear the cost have the greatest
authority of choosing who gets to
enforce that law and I think I sort of
correlated this I'm not surprised that
the first city to go after a police
involved shooting incredibly
aggressively was Baltimore because the
Baltimore state's attorney does not have
a ring suburb to respond to as she's
elected by the city of Baltimore and
therefore does not have that they need
to soup and er to a disproportionately
conservative wide electorate that thinks
cops don't make mistakes right it didn't
happen in Dallas
it happened in Baltimore that's not a
mistake Antonia reflects this very
dangerous separation of cost and
benefits and by the way always comes
back a lot of it comes back to race
right why is there a separation is that
history of redlining and the GI Bill
that only sides of white people not the
black people that that creates is this
incredibly powerful class and social to
say that that's ribbon through by by
racial gaps that they need empathy gaps
in and so on yeah and our problem is it
there is no due process party right if
someone asks you what's law and order
party you might say Republican or you
might say Republican and really lawful
Democrats as long as I can remember but
there's no due process party there's no
rational choices about resource
allocation party there's no cost-benefit
party there's law and order and we're
all on order to right and there's
nowhere you go to say this is a group of
people itself identify as people who are
interested in as as their guiding
principle as something they're proud of
as something they talk about
as protecting the due process of
criminal defendants of making rational
choices
about resource allocation and how many
people were going to put in prison
there's a ratchet only goes in one
direction and that cuts across otherwise
what you see is liberal and conservative
maybe in the Warren court era you could
identify one side or the other as being
more about due process but at least
since Nixon it's all about law and order
and so you know even in a place like
where I live a very blue state like
California we get Democrat after
Democrat after Democrat senator voting
for a criminal justice agenda that's
fundamentally indistinguishable from
what Nixon would want there is no
political party there is no political
movement other than libertarians there
is no I should say large winning big
elections political party that is giving
the other side of the story that it's
saying others anything other than you
know if I say there should be a 10-year
sentence well by God no he said ten I
say 15 you know who cares about more
it's the one who said 15 so shifting
gears I would like to talk about the
recent memo that Attorney General Jeff
Sessions issued to federal prosecutors
which directs prosecutors to charge and
pursue the most serious readily provable
offense this is open to either of you
what sort of impact do you think that
this will have and did former attorney
general holders memo which directed
prosecutors to quote declined to charge
drug defendants with quantities that
would trigger mandatory minimum
sentences if they meet certain criteria
does that really does this memo really
change that it's sessions memo undoing
reforms or what kind of impact are these
memos have my sense is it's mostly
cosmetic so what you're dealing with
here are the rules
for imposing mandatory minimum sentences
right so in federal court you charge
someone with a certain weight of any
given drug that automatically triggers a
certain mandatory minimum sentence it's
different for different drugs a
relatively small amount of
we'll get you a higher mandatory minimum
the same amount of cocaine and it's
always been the rule that the federal
prosecutors are supposed to charge the
most serious readily provable offense so
once it's charged and someone is hit
with this mandatory minimum it's hard to
get out from under it it constrains the
judges power the only way the judge can
sentence less than that mandatory
minimum is that the person cooperates if
they rat and the prosecutors ask the
judge to give them credit because of
that or if they meet a fairly narrow set
of circumstances called the safety valve
which basically mean if you've had two
DUIs you're out of luck you have to have
a extremely minor criminal record and
meet a bunch of other factors what the
holder memo did was say okay now and
then
prosecutors in your discretion you can
decide if it meets all these factors to
charge drug cases in a way that don't
trigger the higher mandatory minimum you
can in effect lie in the charging
documents about how much of the drug is
involved so that the judges hands are
not tied and what the sessions memo said
is that's all Obama [ __ ] it's all
back to the way it was before but in
reality in practicing in a very high
volume district I didn't see a lot of
cases being influenced by the holder
memoranda because what the holder
memorandum really did you might see it
as like a lenient policy or something
that is progressive what it really is is
giving power to prosecutors the power
they didn't have before they had an
obligation to hit you with that
mandatory minimum if it was there all of
a sudden they have discretion to hit you
with it or not hit you with it so how is
that discretion going to be used it's
mostly going to be used to flip people
as co-operators or as a hammer to get
what they want
that's the way prosecutorial discretion
is generally used so all that really
happened in the sequence of events was
the holder memorandum gave Pross
kut'rs more individual discretion over
how many decades people were going to
stay in prison and these sessions
memorandum took it away again I haven't
seen statistics I don't know there are
some but I haven't seen anything
reliable that a lot of cases were
actually impacted by this have you seen
any statistics John I have data guy I
mean the best I saw was in some op-ed
holder himself wrote he claims as
something like 8,000 cases were affected
by the memo which I was doing an upper
estimate of its impact and given the
feds incarcerate 200,000 people that's
the upper bound on what the holder memo
did right so something less than that
and it's not that big an impact and I
was just the impact is even less for
another reason we talk a lot about the
feds we talk a lot of help I mean a lot
about the feds and the reason why I'm
kind of rolling when I talk about the
feds in DC which I realize is perhaps
not the best place to roll your eyes
talking about the feds it's good the
feds take up 100% of our conversation
but they have 12% of prisoners right 88
percent of all prisoners are held by the
states not by the fence they tried the
system if you take two two states there
are most different in how they behave
when it comes to criminal justice and
over they are but whichever they are
those two states have more in common
with each other than any state has in
common with events
the feds are a unique bizarre creature
with its own unique set of incredibly
remarkable pathologies which wherever
problems the states have the feds are
worse for reasons I could spend an hour
telling you about but you can't
extravagant the feds to the states and
holders member will have no IDE we love
close to no impact whatsoever on the
states the reason I think that is what
governors do have almost no impact on
what das do lots of times
my favorite example this other
Rockefeller drug laws in 1973 New York
State start his drug war when Nelson
Rockefeller pushed through the
Rockefeller drug laws in order not to be
a Rockefeller Republican tough for him
there with that last name but that was
the goal of the Rockefeller drug laws
between 1973 and 1980 for the number of
people in New York state prison for
drugs went up slightly and then fell by
1984 ten years in an Oxford drug laws
there are fewer people in New York state
prisons for drugs those laws were first
implemented
Bob Barr said war on drugs and the DEA
said no not for us when when does it
spike its spikes in 84 crack right crack
vials rolls out across New York State
DA's crackdown and by 1990 something
mid-1990s New York State has a higher
sher people in prison for drugs than
with any other stay in the country
because they're using drugs to go after
the violence the other remarkable thing
that New York a prison population arts
dropping in 1999 entirely because five
DEA stopped charging drug cases New York
State has been incarcerated since 1989
the New York State dignity carcere a new
york city Dakar serated the rest of the
state got harsher New York City got less
harsh were just such a giant share of
the population did we drove being stars
entire state trend but that's a climb
starts six years before any change the
rock for our drug laws right five DEA
sat down in their own offices on our own
said we're done with this like finals is
gone we're not crossing you out cases it
might not even intentional but they
chose to simply stop doing this right
and and so I don't think sessions been
mattered that much because DA's don't
even pay attention to governor right
they're certainly not going to care as
taking place in DC or if they do they're
using as cover for their own agenda
right but their inquiry it's hard to
understate how incredibly independent
they are legally I think also an
incredibly independent they are
culturally right and how we know they
are from each other right within New
York State counties moving in gravity
different directions you only state that
the car straight is California right
we're all but one County has shrunk
since 2010 and that one County is some
sizable but very punitive County summer
on the coast I saw something but
everywhere else
we were the state has gone down counties
are moving in various directions and
there's enough counties going down they
offset the ones going up and that's why
I think session that equal derailed
police uniform I think the Fed bully
pulpit matters for policing but prisoner
forms fail is not because the DC there's
lots of ways you can fail on its own but
sessions doesn't make me nervous at all
I saw you shaking your head when he said
that holter well know what with holder
how he he wrote about how his memo
affected like 8,000 cases or something
like that you don't think that that's
not what you saw you're skeptical about
that I'm skeptical just because I'm
skeptical that that many would fall into
the range where people would want to use
that holder memo power during that time
so like Los Angeles the Central District
California one of the biggest population
federal districts in the country indict
maybe 1,200 cases a year so and so I I
suspect the 8,000
some sort of razzle dazzle about this is
these are the cases to which it could
have applied or which we considered
applying it or something like that
okay so the next question one asks is
about recent District Attorney races
that have a number of counties have
recently unseated these tough-on-crime
district attorneys like Angela Cory in
Florida she was replaced by someone who
was branding herself as a reformer
Melissa Nelson in Cook County
Kim Fox won her election against Anita
Alvarez and the list continues I mean
there's been I think a dozen or so
counties that have now elected
reform-minded DA's at least that's how
they're being presented to the in the
press and elsewhere and I want to ask
you both like what do you think these
elections mean I mean we're talking
about how important the role or how
important of a role prosecutors play in
the criminal justice system is this is
this how we start to see reform is by
electing more reform-minded DA's does it
not really matter um you know just what
is your take on that I don't know we
have no idea I mean we're from an
empirical point of view we are in
uncharted waters in so many different
ways that's almost impossible to draw
firm conclusions on anything if I can't
see the data I get antsy but I would say
this it could matter it might not matter
and I think Chicago and Houston arguing
very interesting cities to track so Kim
odd one is reformer Houston Kim Fox
one's reformer in Chicago the day after
she won her election Kim announced that
when she took over the job she was
firing the entire senior management of
relevant 50 lawyers all the door the day
she started the entire just decapitated
the management for whatever reason Kim
Fox didn't or couldn't do that in
Chicago I think it's be a very
interesting difference to track because
the data taught matters what you have on
all of us with 200 attorneys neither Kim
is overseeing gaited operations and you
still have that middle level that's
incredibly punitive running the show I'm
not convinced that top-level directly
that's gonna make its way all the way
down to the rank and file second you
know two years out of Law School a DA we
just buck you know just wanted a trial
experience to get the white-collar
defense job three years out of
Yeah right what to write you you know a
bad thing necessarily but so I but no so
I'll be very honest thing CBC different
I mean obviously there's a lot more
disease used in Chicago it's a promising
right I can't necessary be a bad thing I
think we're putting too much hope that
that that you can transform an office
overnight are we see as with policing
right that what were former so many
policing is it takes three police chiefs
to change an office right the first two
reforms are getting is fired with
nothing happening right because they're
going to try to change it in the unions
are can just grind them down and destroy
them right but by the time the third
chief gets appointed try to put Porter
agenda there's not enough turnover in
the police force thing adjectives
shifted the Union starting to waver a
little bit and then reform will happen
and I think that's probably gonna be
chewing DLC you don't apply the same
organized resistance in the in the form
of a uniform like a union policy above
policing by that culture it's deep and
it's embedded and so it's a start I
think in make a difference to me in
theory if it works we don't need any
reforms at all at the legislative level
right you want BL reform right to take
your da stop demanding cash bail right
let Larry Craster says he's going to do
right I'm just not going to have bail
done right you have your imaginary
minimum done just don't charge him right
you want here have long sentences great
don't fit don't demand them right don't
don't play also long to anything you
want the DA could do it today right they
don't there's culture reasons why they
don't understand that we could do
everything we want now and if we don't
is because there's something deeper
about that cultures we're finding hard
to fight and we've never seen the
cultures change this often this quickly
in this many different places so it'd be
really fast over the next three four
five six years see what happens but if
you want you want me to say what does it
mean I mean invite me back in 20 22 or
so and I should have some pretty good
answers for you by then but it will be
interesting to watch I think it's a
prime but really hard to predict what's
going to happen
ken do you have any thoughts on these
elections if you're if you're hopeful or
are you just more libertarian and
pessimistic I own like Miami cynically
hopeful so you know I see a few things
going on one I see that there's always
going to be resistance to reform so you
see down in Florida
with the DEA who decided they were going
to dramatically change the way they
didn't change charged death penalties
and they're getting huge push
back from the Attorney General and on
the whole state political apparatus
basically I'm skeptical in that I think
a lot of things that are generally
labeled as reform are going to be
relatively cosmetic or going to involve
some pilot programs but not as John
suggested changing the day-to-day bread
and butter of the office that's the
stuff
das could like John said make dramatic
changes but so far I don't see that
happening and I'm not sure that they
feel the political support to do that in
an open Hey look I'm a reformed DEA type
of way the five DA's in New York that
that John talked about who changed the
way drug charges were done I don't think
one out there and say hey I'm the new
different charging drug person and this
is our whole new policy that it probably
wouldn't have sold particularly well
that way because again I don't think
there's a political constituency there's
not a natural political support for DA's
to be like that there's no due process
part so it's not a bad thing but I also
think it's going to take a long time and
the DA's offices particularly the right
rank-and-file are going to continue to
reflect the culture and unless the
culture changes and can then I don't
think that the whole process changes
that much to me
I think me the fascinating case that
look back on think about is Seth
Williams I put aside the corruption in
the cash the action like federal charges
i Williams was announced and held Ltda
he was elected as reformer and ended his
career putting again brings I corruption
even even though corruption the reform
movement turned against Williams for
being eel of juvenile life without
parole he's incredibly harsh he fought
resentencing at the Supreme Court for
juvenile life with lifers and the
question I have about Williams is
there's three possibilities right one is
he was never a former at all he just
pretended he went to get elected in a
fairly liberal City maybe the second is
that well was so the other big one I
wonder what's the second is that is that
maybe here's her former but what we
think was reformer in simply shifted
we've become more progress
he was a reformer for when he won and
just just the world has moved past him
but what concerns me there's a third
option I think he was actually much more
of a reformer but instead of reforming
the office
the officer formed him right is that's
why I wonder like these days come in and
there are groups in place now they're
trying to help all these new days talk
to each other thinking sort of trade
ideas and kind of stay strong against a
public that's still kind of worried
about this I wanted to what extent can
be a change officers are being changed
themselves by that power responsibility
in political pressures okay so something
we hear time and time again at least in
the work that I do I'm primarily do like
sentencing reform stuff at the state
level whenever there's a new sentencing
reform piece of legislation that's been
proposed
we always hear these loud voices of
prosecutors saying that you know they
are in the best position to impose the
most appropriate sentence like they
should be trusted with the discretion
here
and that if we remove these mandatory
minimums that allow them to exercise
discretion when it comes to plea
bargaining and things like that you know
they're really in the best position to
to impose these sentences and they have
victims in mind so it's another thing it
sounds ridiculous saying it out loud
especially in this room with people who
are more reform minded but we see it
time and time again in newspapers across
the country so I wanted to get your
thoughts on that especially from you Ken
like was this something that you really
believed while you were a federal
prosecutor that you should be trusted
with this power because you understand
the law and you have the victims in mind
of these crimes when it is a victim
crime I like to think I wasn't quite
that self-important but I I certainly
had an attitude that I was part of a
team that knew the right way to do
things and that it was natural and right
that I had this level of power I mean I
remember I was 26 and I had to make a
decision about what type of plea to
offer to a guy who'd jacked five banks
and been unfortunate enough to get
caught with the actual real firearm in
the plea I offered him with determine
whether he was going to do you know 25
mandatory minimum or 35 mandatory
minimum
or 75 mandatory minimum which in federal
prison you do the whole thing so you
know you're leaving in a box and I was a
26 year old and I was going to make the
recommendation of my supervisor how much
time this guy was going to get and I was
probably going to get what I asked for
and now I'm just appalled by that
because now prosecutors do not have any
sort of special knowledge or insight
they are part of a culture that has very
specific views and pathologies and the
way the system is supposed to work is
that they are one voice right that we're
supposed to have someone working very
hard for the defense and someone working
very hard for the prosecution and maybe
someone supposedly neutral like the
probation office and then a judge is
supposed to sort out the the competing
voices and unfortunately too often and I
find much more in state court than
federal the the tie goes easily to the
DA the DA is on training wheels
basically and the judges give gigantic
deference to them because of precisely
the attitude that you're talking about
so the DA's can you know wandering the
court do stuff that I could never get
away with as a defense lawyer
the DA's are also far from having an
accurate view of everything I think are
very much driven again by that by their
culture and a big part of that culture
is fear I don't mean so much fear of
crime even though that's what they get
fed by our culture every day that you
know we're in constant peril even though
realistically the crime rate is down
dramatically I mean that the fear of
blowing it the fear of getting tricked
so the bad guy gets away the fear of
being someone who lets someone off easy
and so they go out and kill somebody
that fear draw has a huge influence on
the way prosecutors think and I saw that
as a prosecutor a number of times can I
tell just one story about a time when
that yeah yeah
so I was given a bank robbery case this
guy gets in a motorcycle accident
seriously injured gets about $25,000 in
an insurance settlement he gets fired
and he goes home from getting fired and
his girlfriend dumps him tells him to
move out so poor bastard goes to the
bank to withdraw some of this insurance
so he can get a new place and you know
have money since he's just spent fired
and the bank teller says oh the
insurance check hasn't cleared yet it's
only been five days so he goes well did
I mention this is a robbery
I have explosives give me my money so
the tower gives them the 1600 bucks in
the tower drawer he walks off leading
the drivers license on the counter he
drives to his girlfriend's apartment
building and sits in his car in the
parking lot crying until he's arrested
how do i prosecuted for bank robbery
given to me and I go to the chief of the
Criminal Division and I say do we really
want to do this I mean do we really want
to prosecute this guy federally for bank
robbery given this chain of events and
the chief criminal says we'll look you
know he's got these three duis in his
past you know ken are you going to be
okay if you let him go someday your wife
is out driving on the road and he's
drunk and he runs into her and why this
is amazing is that this chief of the
Criminal Division is a fair-minded
incredibly smart decent man that I have
nothing but respect for but he and I
were completely captured by the system
and that fear the fear that this guy was
going to go out and kill somebody even
though he was a complete sad sack was so
much more powerful than the fear that we
were doing a great injustice by
prosecuting him federally or the fear in
any case is that we were doing something
that violated rights or that someone
might be actually the instance innocent
this has a slightly happy ending though
because the jury hung 11 to 1 for Coyle
after hearing the facts because you know
it was [ __ ] and I would add that we
have a very dangerously narrow view we
talk about victims and I always get in
trouble for making this appointment
people but it's an incredibly important
point to make when we talk in crime is
hugely costly you do not want to
understand the cost of crime right not
just a cost the victims there's evidence
I want the greatest harm since early
child development to educational
attainment therefore the career
attainment is exposure to file it's not
being the victim just being in a high
violence area has incredibly massive
harms two children and two adults and a
families and you don't understand that
and we don't that's a cost we talk about
cost item for prisons the other cost end
is the 50 billion dollars you spend on
prison that's the analysis but that's
wrong because there's another big cost
to punish it we always ignore prison is
a major factor of tuberculosis HIV and
STDs the risk of dying for a drug
overdose skyrockets upon release because
you go from using extensive low quality
drugs to cheap high quality drugs and so
many people diving overdoses they don't
call it a prison death but it's prison
that killed them a study in New York
State found that in the short to medium
term one-year prison takes two years off
your expected lifespan prison causes it
causes people are already on the edge of
poverty to have their wages go down
hours work down total income drops
overall impact an economy is slight but
in fact for that person fiscally is
devastating it's a major factor pushing
women on the welfare when their partner
goes to prison it pushes kids into crime
from the lack of a parent at home it
throws off daily markets right dating
functions in neighborhood winds 5050
figures that mail favors end female and
people don't get far outside their
neighborhoods in some high enforcement
neighborhoods that ratio is 6040 all
right 60 percent of females forty
percent male because there's so many men
in prison and that leads to more single
parenthood higher rates of STD
transition other problems of family
formation there's a cost to collect
calls to prison in New York State half
of all prisoners come from New York City
but half our maximum security prisons
are at least 200 miles away from the
city some 300 miles away right to got
transportation costs hotel costs forgone
labor forgone income cost and you take
time to go visit person in prison right
the social and epidemiological and
health and physical and emotional and
familial cost of incarceration are
staggering and we can't count them we
don't know how to comfort we haven't
begun to count them there was one state
I tried and it was
bless their heart as my southern wife
would say for trying but we really have
no idea what these costs are by
guarantee you that that's 50 billion
dollars you spend in cash on
incarceration that's at the tip of an
iceberg and there are a lot of victims
who aren't necessarily terms of crime
it's the kids and the partners and the
people themselves I mean the people in
prison are still people the last time I
checked I asked the kind of a
controversial position if you somebody
committed crimes to a person but they
are these are real cost the physical
harms the sexual assault harms right
there are a tremendous amount of cost
and victimization that goes on with the
punishment system itself and you know
the DA's when they say we see for the
victim they're speaking for one very
narrow victim and the faculty mentor so
you do a survey of victims of a well
designed survey of victims they deliver
safety and justice as did one victims of
crimes tend to be young male people con
right it's not the suburban white
housewife you think of right and they
have a much more sophisticated view of
what they want they want punishment but
something much more restorative and
focused on justice something less
punitive because they themselves have
been exposed to curls dusted on the
other side their brother their uncle
their nephews been exposed they
understand how the system works and they
don't have this suburban harshness that
gays tend to bring to the table so we
actually want to respect the victim it's
all a lot more complicated in your
average DA makes it sound and the DA's
aren't only speaking for the actual
victims right they're thinking of these
more suburban victims with a much
different take on how crime operates how
house you dealt with okay so this
conversation has been pretty depressing
uh-huh and it seems like there's no hope
so I'd like to ask my final question
then we'll act we'll move on to audience
questions briefly but just with
something hopeful if you could reform
one to two practices of prosecutors or
something about the prosecutor's office
that you think would actually make a big
impact a positive impact what would it
be
is there anything or are we just all
doomed
no so there's hope and I will say that
we have I think of a far ways to go one
of the most consistent critiques of my
book which actually admit as a perfectly
fair critique all that well my spin on
is different is that the weakest part of
my solutions part all right two entire
responses I know right because no one's
talking about prosecutors no one's
talking about you
means no once I want the political
defects and so I'm just thinking some
ideas I say let's try this to start but
there I think they're way too can fix at
least we didn't focus on the wrong
things for too long but one hopeful
glimmer I would say is you know one of
the two candidates in 2016 ran on a
rather tough on crime we're all going to
hell
carnage in America platform and one of
the states that voted most strongly for
Trump was Oklahoma 6535 I think was how
they went for Trump at the same time
they passed two statewide referendum to
the exact same electorate that
decriminalized a large amount of drugs
and shifted that money from punishment
into treatment it's a start it's someone
who's not focused on violence over half
of all people in prison are there for
violence sixty percent for drugs this
whole it's all a little nonviolent drug
offenders is wrong it's it's mid-level
drug people and a lot of people
convicted of violence but it's a start
right
Oklahoma which has the second highest
and soon to be first highest they keep
it up and car serration rate was still
willing to embrace reform right so
there's hope there what perform what I
have I think we need to adopt charging
in plea bargain guidelines for
prosecutors we tie judges hands all the
time right and the best comment ever
heard about pre bart about mandatory
minimums actually I think I didn't
notice wasn't like great it was someone
else from town at the time said what
mandatory minimums are is proof that we
trust a prosecutor right up until the
minute we elect and judge right because
we was a judge generally a former
prosecutor right we don't trust them as
judges we tied our hands as sentencing
guidelines and mandatory minimums and
all these rules when they're older and
more experienced and less partisan right
so we should do the same thing to
prosecutors these guys are 26 year old
channels law school trying to do the
best they can but we rascally decided
does this guy pose a risk do you have to
lock this person up dzr had these in
english and those social psychology
training know psychology training those
social science they're being asked to
make incredibly difficult policy
questions and notice about the english
majors but you guys aren't good at math
right and and it's a mathematical issue
right like is this guy a risk that's an
empirical question and we're asking a 25
year old to make that call that's not
right we're asking to make all these
decisions as no guides no help no
assistance New Jersey has plea bargain
guidelines for some drug offenses we can
do this right and we tie of judges I
don't and why
restraining prosecutors just the same
kind of way so that that's what I think
it's possible I think we should do it
da sounds like me when I say that but I
think that's a good time I feel I got a
lot out of my physics and math for poets
track in college Sean and I'm a little
triggered by that be perfectly honest I
would say something similar I think
something encouraging that I see that
has been betrayed portrayed by some is
something terrible is that socially I
think we've moved away from a huge
consensus that at the police shoot
somebody probably had it coming right I
think the questioning whether force was
appropriate has become more mainstream
across the country and in more and more
communities some people see that as
horrific maybe our Attorney General I
see that as good I think it is possible
to bring some of that same skepticism
towards prosecutorial decisions and the
way I would like to see it happen is to
have something like the police
commissions the civilian police
commissions we see in a lot of big
cities that review use of force and
police actions and have prosecutorial
Commission's have Commission's that
review things like allegations of
prosecutorial misconduct review
practices and things like that I would
also like to see state bars as long as
I'm getting anything I want I would like
to see state bars devote more resources
and even have specialists dealing with
prosecutorial misconduct because part of
the wall of prosecutors can do no wrong
that helps make the system opaque gives
them so much power that we don't even
really understand is the lack of
substantive review it is incredibly rare
for state bars to impose consequences on
prosecutors for things that if I did as
a defense lawyer my card would be gone
in a heartbeat I think if we had those
sorts of systems in place the operation
of them public operation of them might
start to make some cultural changes the
way I think that oversight of police has
started to have
the last two decades alright well thank
you guys all for coming and let's give a
round of applause to our fantastic
panelists I learned a lot thank you
there's there's beers you guys can keep
drinking but not for too long we're
going to cut you off there - yeah thank
you good
[Music]